Salut, aujourd'hui on est mercredi et c'est donc le jour de l'astuce de la semaine
Je suis un petit peu, mais alors un tout petit peu à la bourre sur le tournage des vidéos
Et donc je vous ai demandé il y a une heure de temps sur Twitter, sur Facebook, sur Instagram et sur Snapchat ce que vous vouliez comme astuce pour aujourd'hui
Et j'ai bien fait de faire ça parce que vous m'avez donné pleins de réponses
Je pensais pas qu'en une heure j'aurais autant de réponses
C'est top. J'en ai donc choisi une pour aujourd'hui et j'en ai gardé une qui me servira samedi pour le Master Class'
Ce sera un Master Class' sur les entretiens d'embauche
Tremblez recruteurs !
Car mes abonnés seront prêt !
Mais aujourd'hui je vais vous parler du démarchage téléphonique
Vous savez ce sont ceux qui vous appellent pour vous vendre quelques choses que ce soit en téléphonie, en assurances ou pleins d'autres choses.
et vous, vous trouvez pris au piège avec un commercial
qui sait très bien faire son boulot
Alors aujourd'hui je vous donne mes 6 astuces face au démarchage téléphonique !
Il faudrait commencer par définir qui sont les personnes qui nous démarchent
les personnes qui sont à l'autre bout du fil.
Ce sont des personnes comme vous et moi
ils travaillent en fait. C'est leur gagne pain
Donc eux ils n'y sont pour rien à la base, ils n'ont pas décidé de vous appeler vous
Tiens je vais essayer de revendre l'assurance à Fabien Olicard aujourd'hui. Ça c'est une bonne idée
Evidemment, c'est un ordinateur qui choisi les noms et les numéros de téléphone, pour eux ils sont devant un écran
Ils ne choisissent pas. Ils y sont pour rien.
C'est important de le dire parce que... mal leur parler ou les envoyer balader ça ne changera rien.
A la limite, ça peut même se retourner contre vous parce qu'ils peuvent vous mettre dans le fichier des clients à appeler, qui n'ont pas été appelés
Juste pour le plaisir, de se dire qu'il y a un autre collègue qui va vous rappeler demain et un autre après demain et un autre après après demain
Et ça, ça m’amène à ma 1ère astuce.
Ma 1ère astuce c'est : Qu'il ne faut pas leur dire que vous n'avez pas le temps maintenant ou que vous êtes pressés
ou même de leur demander de vous rappelez plus tard
Eux, ils n'entendent qu'une seule chose quand vous dites je n'ai pas le temps
Ça veut dire je n'ai pas le temps pour le moment mais je veux bien être démarcher
C'est une manière pour eux de vous remettre dans le fichier clients, des clients à rappeler plus tard
Vous n'allez pas, vous débarrassez d'eux comme ça
parce que c'est pas Nicolas derrière son standard, qui a son fichier de client à appeler.
Je vous rappelle. C'est un ordinateur c'est un fichier informatique
donc si vous dites à la personne qui vous appelle je n'ai pas le temps
Il va vous dire ok il y a pas de problème, on peut vous appelez quand?
Ah je sais pas en fin de semaine, un truc comme ça
Il vous remet dans leur fichier client, le fichier des gens à rappeler et ne vous inquiétez pas vous serez rappelé. Y'a pas de problème avec ça
Ce qui m'amène à la 2ième astuce
qui est aussi simple. La 2ième astuce c'est:  Ne leur raccrochez pas au nez
Ne leur parlez pas violemment pour leur raccrocher au nez
ça ne marche pas non plus, ça vous remet dans....
Le fichier client, tu avais deviné.
La 3ième astuce, c'est de ne jamais s'intéresser à ce qu'ils viennent vous apporter
ce qu'ils viennent vous vendre parce qu'en réalité même si c'est pas clairement énoncé comme ça, ils ont toujours quelque chose à vendre. Evidemment
Ils appellent pas pour prendre de vos nouvelles
C'est très rare ça quand même
Ne montrez jamais un signe comme quoi vous êtes intéressés
donc ne leur posez pas de questions, ne montrez pas d'intérêt, ne discutez pas avec eux, c'est pas votre copain, c'est pas votre pote
il faut pas discuter, ça sert à rien du tout
il faut surtout clore ce débat et faire en sorte que l'on nous vous rappelle pas
D'ailleurs n'essayez jamais d'argumenter avec eux pour leur prouver qu'ils ont tort sur le produit.
Et pourquoi, il faut pas argumenter avec eux
Ben je vais vous le dire
Parce que derrière cette procédure téléphonique
il y a quelqu'un, comme moi,
qui a pris le temps de leur faire un petit arbre des possibilités
quelqu'un qui anticipe vos réponses à l'avance
qui vas anticiper un argumentaire
donc vous n'aurez pas d'arguments valable auxquelles ils n'auront pas de réponses
Quoi qu'il arrive, ils auront une réponse.
Ils ont un arbre comme ça des possibles et ils suivent le cheminement
C'est pas eux qui réfléchissent en temps réél
ils lisent juste un document pour ça on argumente pas
4ième astuces, si on veut vous vendre un produit classique
comme de la téléphonie, une assurance, une box internet, ce genre de produit là
il y a un argument ultime
qui est imparable, qui va clore la conversation tout de suite
parce ça, ils n'ont plus rien après
c'est de dire que c'est votre employeur qui vous le paie
Mais c'est un mensonge ça Fabien.
Oui mais c'est un bon mensonge pour ne plus être appeler
Si on vous propose de changer d'opérateur téléphonique par exemple
Dites: "Mais non c'est pas moi qui m'en occupe, c'est mon employeur qui me paie ça, parce que j'ai un très bon employeur
qui me paie tout
et je ne m'occupe de rien.
Ils ne pourront pas vous faire changer d'opérateur puisque vous n'êtes plus le décideur
alors à partir du moment où vous n'êtes plus le décideur, vous n'êtes pas la bonne personne à appeler
et vous disparaissez du fichier
eh eh eh
Parfois cette astuce là, ne fonctionne pas
et c'est pour ça que j'appelle ici, aujourd'hui et maintenant l'astuce n°5
Par exemple, quelqu'un qui appelle en disant: Bonjour, c'est EDF je vous appelle pour faire un point sur votre ligne
On ne va pas se mentir tu vas avoir du mal à lui faire croire que c'est ton employeur qui paie ta facture d'électricité
Faut peut-être pas déconner non plus
et il y a de fortes chances que ce ne soit pas EDF qui soit au bout du fil aussi
J'utilise toujours la même astuce
Je leur demande toujours mon identifiant
Vous allez sentir un léger bug de l'autre côté
et vous dites clairement: Ecoutez tant que vous n'êtes pas capable de donner mon numéro de client chez vous
Je ne répondrais pas à vos questions. Merci de ne plus me rappeler tant que vous ne l'avez pas
C'est magique, c'est testé, c'est éprouvé par Bibi
On ne vous rappelle plus
Et la dernière astuce,
elle est censé fonctionner dans 100% des cas
parce qu'elle se base, aussi, sur la loi
malheureusement, elle ne fonctionne pas à chaque fois
mais ça vaut le coup de le faire parce que ça va éliminer des coups de fil à répétition
à la toute fin de la conversation, au moment où ils prennent congé de vous, assez rapidement
donc saisissez l'instant parce qu'une fois qu'ils ont compris qu'avec vous ils pouvaient plus rien faire
Ils se dépêchent à vous dire au revoir
Demandez d'être sur la liste des personnes à ne plus rappeler
Pas à être effacer du fichier
Si vous vous faites effacer du fichier, vous pouvez vous faire réinscrire un autre jour
donc vous demandez à être inscrit dans le fichier des personnes qui ne doivent plus être contactées
C'était donc les 6 astuces pour ne plus être embêter par le démarchage téléphonique
Ce sont mes vraies astuces, c'est celle que j'utilise vraiment
vous m'avez posé cette question il y a une heure sur Instagram
Je recommencerai ça sur d'autres mercredis
et je vous annonce un nouvel objectif
Mon objectif il est à 2500 abonnés
c'est un objectif que je place ici, aujourd'hui, je le place là, je le place ici
tout autour de moi
Dés qu'on sera 2500 abonnés, je monterai une diffusion, soit sur périscope, soit sur YouTube
Je ne sais pas encore en live avec vous
On pourra discuter en direct, se faire des trucs de mentalisme en fait
On se prendra une heure tous ensemble. Un espèce d'apéro géant
mais où chacun amène sa boisson et reste chez lui
On se fait ça à 2500 abonnés donc je compte sur vous.
Si vous êtes pas abonnés à la page, cliquez sur le bouton Abonne toi
Si vous êtes un blog ou un journal et que vous comptez reprendre mes astuces
Vous le pouvez mais mettez ma vidéo et citez moi ça me fait plaisir
Sinon après je suis très très triste et c'est déjà arrivé 2 fois
Si cette vidéo vous a plu partagez la partout sur internet ça peut servir à pleins d'autres personnes que vous
Et on se retrouve demain à 17h pour le prochain MentalVlog. Ciao!